Mattel immediately shook his head five  seconds to react to this we said earlier  two pawns on the sixth rank here White's  third rank oh make a move and he's just  retreated The Rook oh no  he's just panicking now  trap the White Queen as well the Black  Knight can come and hit the queen and  she's trapped  we will see oh boy  Nowhere to Run no squares  his back Pawn's too strong  play another move  or hat okay he does but this one is  hopeless the White Queen is simply  captured Queen down and he's gonna  resign  gonna be a win for your cash  what a good fight though by additional  yeah  and we can't blame him blame him for  playing on it's been a really  fascinating game and black spawns are  just too strong there we go we have the  result there it is over that means  gukesh is definitely ready for The  Knockout stage with uh 24.7